à londres les s'offrir essaie toujours
de retrouver la vingtaine de personnes
disparues les enquêteurs où est
actuellement la coque du night-club
flottant qui a coulé hier soir dix corps
ont été retrouvés françois mitterrand
quelques heures à madrid de passage
quelques heures à madrid affirme que les
navires français sont en mission de
prouver de sauvegarde il appelle à une
intensification diplomatique louvière
menace les soldats neg pologne
le nouveau premier ministre pressenti
exposé son programme à la télévision
pour la première fois ils demandent aux
polonais de se débarrasser du désespoir
ventes de yearlings à deauville les prix
ne sont plus ce qu'ils étaient le record
atteint à peine 6 millions et demi de
francs un reportage à la fin que ce jour
non mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir
le capitaine de la drague qui a heurté
de plein fouet le bateau nightclub sur
la tamise a été arrêté ainsi que son
second après avoir été prenez vous le
savez le bateau de promenade a coulé
presque immédiatement il y avait à bord
environ 120 passagers pour le moment 20
personnes manquent à l'appel dix corps
ont été retrouvés louis gazeau deux
minutes il aura suffi de deux minutes
seulement pour que le march madness
coule au fond de la tamise et lorsque
l'accident survient 120 personnes à bord
célèbre un anniversaire à tarnos j'ai
plongé
et puis j'ai été emporté par le vent
submergée par l'eau pendant quelques uns
et les autres je ne me suis pas
retournée il saisit très sombre soppec
j'ai vu le tanker arrivé sur nous et
nous rentrer dedans alors j'ai plongé à
travers la fenêtre
il y avait plein de gens en bas de
l'escalier et pas d'issue je ne sais pas
comment ils ont pu sortir
le choc est terrible la drague bomb elle
percute deux fois le bateau mouche 3000
tonnes contre 90 les sauveteurs ont
passé la nuit à rechercher d'éventuels
rescapés à l'aide d'immenses projecteurs
le courant ne permet pas
l'intervention des plongeurs le seul
camp retrouver le sera d'ailleurs près
du pont dame smith à 12 kilomètres de
l'accident
ce matin les autorités londonnienne ont
décidé la fermeture de la barrière de la
tamise qui contrôle les marais à
l'embouchure du fleuve
le trafic est même interdit pour
faciliter la recherche des disparus
le premier ministre britannique en
vacances en autriche est rentré
d'urgence pour se rendre sur les lieux
du drame
interrogé depuis hier soir par scotland
yard le capitaine du bo belle et son
second ont été arrêtés en fin d'après
midi mais on ignore toujours pourquoi la
drague est venu percuter le bateau
mouche ce soir les chances de retrouver
les trente disparus semblent minces
les pompiers en commençant les
opérations de levage ont découvert
l'épave du march madness tout simplement
coupé en deux si l'on en croit
associatedpress la police britannique a
annoncé ce soir que les disparus
pourraient le nombre des disparus
pourraient s'élever à 60 et non à 30
comme annoncé auparavant le nouveau
premier ministre polonais pressenti
était cet après midi pour sa première
sortie officielle avec danse où l'on
célébrait l'anniversaire de la signature
des fameux accords il a rencontré lech
walesa mais n'a pas pu encore parler de
la constitution de son nouveau
gouvernement
les choses restent encore indécises le
cna ligne depuis plusieurs semaines les
militants de solidarité avaient prévu de
fêter le 10ème anniversaire des accords
de danse par amara toi
histoire de montrer leur ténacité et
leur résistance
il ne savait pas alors que la vedette
leur serait ravie par un nouveau premier
ministre issu de leurs rangs
celui-ci tadeus mazowiecki avaient fait
le voyage de danse que pour ce premier
dimanche officiel est déjà sur lui
s'abattait les meute de journalistes qui
viennent du monde entier découvrir le
premier dirigeant non communiste limpide
l'aise pour entretien avec les cheveux
les a dans le presbytère et les deux
hommes vont ensemble assister à la messe
la foule enfin laisse éclater sa joie
alors que les cheveux les arts a de plus
en plus de mal à dissimuler son émotion
et de la foule qui a envahi l'église
jaillit spontanément l'hymne national il
dit tant que nous vivrons la pologne
vivre à ce que les ninjas prix
lui reprendront
à
m
le père jankowski présente à des
ossements de vince qui à la foule des
fidèles avec ces mots voici le premier
premier ministre catholique de la
polaire
l'émotion est à son comble dans cette
église de danse qui depuis 1981 servi de
refuge à tous ceux qui luttèrent pour
plus de démocratie et de liberté est la
messe terminée chacun sentait qu'on ne
pouvait se quitter comme cela les
grilles du presbytère cède sous la
pression de la foule et un meeting
improvisé s'organisent les jeux les arts
trouve sa voie le tribun nous avons
gagné la bataille du pluralisme et nous
sommes sur la route de la démocratie
il nous faut maintenant réapprendre à ne
plus vivre dans le désespoir tadeus
mazowiecki prend ensuite la parole
je veux vous dire ce que je me dis à moi
même osons croire que nous sommes assez
forts pour assumer les tâches qui nous
attendent nous devons
un reportage de jacques molina et
dominique merlin il semble que la
répression face de moins en moins
recette dans les pays de l'est surtout
quand passent les caméras de télévision
hier 500 allemands de l'est se sont
mêlés à une manifestation qui était
destinée à couper symboliquement les
barbelés du rideau de fer qui sépare la
hongrie de nos tristes bien c'est à ce
moment là que les allemands de l'est
sont passés à l'ouest et sharbini ils
sont fous de joie ils ont réussi ces
deux jeunes allemands de rfa viennent de
passer à l'ouest
il s'était rendu en hongrie un visa
touristique en poche depuis il attendait
de passer en autriche l'occasion elle
s'est présentée hier exceptionnellement
les autorités hongroises avaient ouvert
le poste frontière de saintes
margarethen pour permettre à leurs
voisins autrichiens de participer à une
manifestation célébrant le démantèlement
du rideau de fer à budapest
l'information s'est répandue comme une
traînée de poudre en trois heures plus
de 500 réfugiés est allemands se sont
précipités à la frontière et se sont
engouffrés dans la brèche septembre
raconte comment il a tenté précédemment
par deux fois de passer la frontière
l'ambassade de rfa explique-t-il nous a
procuré des passeports ouest allemand
nous nous sommes représentés à pied les
douaniers nous ont laissé passer sans
difficulté
ils ne nous ont même pas demander le
visa d'entrée en hongrie qui auraient
prouvé que nous étions vraiment des
citoyens est-allemands
en fait il semble bien que les autorités
hongroises ou pas chercher à enrayer
cette fuite massive
chaque jour à budapest les réfugiés sont
plus nombreuses la hongrie ne plus
laisser filer sans se brouiller avec
l'allemagne de l'est
elle a sans doute préféré ouvrir à
soupapes quitte à fermer les yeux
françois mitterrand s'est rendu
aujourd'hui à madrid où il a rencontré
felipe gonzalez pour une visite
informelle au cours de la conférence de
presse qui a suivi le président de la
république a pour la première fois
évoqué en public le rôle qu'entend jouer
la france au liban au micro de bernard
pradines qui pourrait songer à s'en
prendre à cette mission humanitaire
d'assistance l'égard de nos compatriotes
toute personne qui estimeraient de
pouvoir trouver secours auprès de la
france donc c'est exclu cette idée qui
pourrait songer à s'en prendre
militairement à du bâtiment à des
navires
dont la mission n'a pas de signification
militaire voilà ce que je puis vous
répondre sur ce point nous continueront
d'exercer ce que notre influence et 2
mettra à la disposition de tous les
libanais et moyens dont nous disposons
pour alléger leurs souffrances au liban
côté musulman on met en garde la france
contre d'éventuelles tentatives de lever
le blocus maritime de l'enclos
chrétienne les précisant les précisions
pardon apporté par françois mitterrand
son nature à lever le doute occasionné
par le départ pour le proche-orient des
navires français logeait hier une
organisation qui détient des otages
américains indique que si la france
comme est je cite une stupidité olly gan
la vie des otages américains seraient
menacés la trêve entre coupé de quelques
salves d'artillerie aura été de courte
durée
les bombardements se poursuivent
principalement la nuit sur le littoral
pour les syriens et sur les batteries
syrienne pour les chrétiens on assiste
une nouvelle fois un exode
les habitants des quartiers musulmans
sans fuite quand ils le peuvent vers le
sud en israël la mort d'un jeune
palestinien de 14 ans déclenché un
véritable scandale
le jeune garçon d'origine américaine a
été retrouvé vendredi dernier tué d'une
balle en pleine poitrine sa famille
prétend même qu'il aurait été torturé
les etats-unis ont exigé une enquête
charles enderlin am djibrila tawil avait
14 ans détenteur également de la
nationalité américaine
il étudiait à ramallah dans cette école
privée bilingue
mercredi dernier des témoins l'ont vu au
cours d'un affrontement avec l'armée
dans la vieille ville d'el bireh à
quelques kilomètres de son domicile
les jeunes manifestants ont pris la
fuite vers les collines il ya eu des
tirs les 48 heures plus tard un berger
découvrait le cadavre de l'enfant
ces images ont été tournées par un
cameraman palestinien selon la famille
un militaire israélien aurait admis cam
jade était détenue par les services de
sécurité
la sphère fait scandale certains
palestiniens accusent l'armée d'avoir
exécuté l'enfant ce que démentent les
militaires nous avons vérifié dans tous
les centres de détention la victime n'a
pas hésité à rester au cours des
dernières semaines
une enquête est en cours s'il ya eu un
accrochage au cours duquel l'enfant été
blessés par un soldat
nous adopterons les conclusions qui
s'imposent
les enquêteurs de l'armée de l'identité
judiciaire étaient sur les lieux
aujourd'hui il semble que le corps soit
resté sur la colline depuis mercredi les
habitants de cette maison proche de
l'endroit où s'est déroulé l'accrochage
n'ont pas vu les soldats arrêté un
manifestant ou emporter un blessé
apparemment les signes découvert sur le
cadavre est interprété par les
palestiniens comme une preuve de torture
proviennent de ce séjour de 48 heures
dans une région sauvage
on ne sait donc toujours pas comment est
mort à monsieur djibril à tawil ce qui
est certain c'est qu'il est là 500 22e
victimes palestiniennes depuis le début
du soulèvement
michel rocard pour sa première journée
en nouvelle calédonie s'est rendu dans
le fief indépendantiste de canala il a
rencontré le numéro trois du fln ks
léopold j'aurais dié le premier ministre
a mis l'accent sur la nécessité du
développement économique
rachid arhab jacques lafleur pour le rpr
ce matin devant le monument aux morts de
nouméa françois bur pour le fln 15 ce
soir dans une réunion mondaine la
première journée de michel rocard en
nouvelle calédonie a été bien remplie le
premier ministre a veillé à respecter
l'équilibré entre indépendantistes et
loyalistes
dans tous ses faits et gestes l'
équilibre politique donc mais aussi
l'équilibré économique en visitant
l'usiné de nickel de nouméa la blanche
michel ropert a confirmé une autre mine
à découvrir dans le nord du pays
en terrains dépendantes lice pour tenter
de répartir les richesses de l'île la
logique des accords de matignon la voilà
en d'action des dispositions juridiques
nouvelle agiront légal dignité et légal
responsabilité de toutes les communautés
les intérêts partagés où chacun
fonctions juste content
la confiance tu sauras chine là où
naguère si riche et des conflits et
violences à cannes à la commune
indépendantiste où il a visité des
chantiers en tout genre michel rocard a
révélé qu'en un an
trois mille emplois avaient été créés en
nouvelle calédonie demain à michel
rocard continuera son numéro
d'équilibriste politique en se rendant
le matin dans la province nord
l'indépendantiste et l'après midi dans
le sud loyaliste
auparavant le premier ministre ira se
recueillir sur la tombe de jean-marie
tjibaou
le leader du fine gael assassiné il ya
quatre mois et dont l'absence plane
toujours sur la nouvelle calédonie le
pape à saint jacques de compostelle a
une nouvelle fois appelé pour qu'un
cessez-le-feu interviennent au liban
jean paul ii s'est adressé aux 450 mille
pèlerins pour leur recommander de ne pas
céder à la tentation de la drogue et
aussi de l'érotisme
le woodstock de la fois comme on appelle
la manifestation de saint jacques de
compostelle a été une véritable réussite
le bilan avec jean-claude d'arrigo 9h ce
matin ils sont 400 milles dans
l'amphithéâtre le pape célèbre la messe
de clôture de la quatrième rencontre
internationale des jeunes 158 d'entre
eux ont dormi sur place
enveloppez vaille que vaille qui dans
des duvets qui dans des toiles de tente
il fait un peu froid et pourtant dès les
premiers instants de la célébration la
ferveur règne et l' enthousiasme dans la
tête de ces jeunes comme un kaléidoscope
de ce qu'ils ont vécu depuis deux jours
les images du pape pèlerin effectuant
tous les gestes et les rites de l'
aventure spirituelle de saint jacques
son regard et ses gestes de tendresse
ces paroles surtout que retentit avec
force dans nos coeurs préparer à les
recevoir
pourtant jean paul denis palle et la
mort ce qu'il a proposé c'est un
christianisme exigeant sur tous les
plans y compris le domaine moral
il a parlé dans un silence profond ou
l'adhésion se devinait
alors qui sont ils ces jeunes qui
semblent être d'accord avec un discours
dont on prétend qu'ils aient refusé ou
contesté jusque dans les rangs des
chrétiens pratiquants bien des jeunes
comme les autres le voient et ils l'ont
montré en installant dans leur fête à
saint jacques une atmosphère la
woodstock des jeunes différent des
autres aussi par leurs choix personnels
le choix explicite du christianisme et
de l'évangile à cela donc jean paul ii
s'est sentie libre de parler avec son
coeur de l'europe chrétienne ils rêvent
de reconstruire
ils sont dit oui à son projet il faudra
désormais compter avec eux aussi bien
dans l'église que dans la société
c'est maintenant officiel
henri xavier lemire involontaire de
l'association handicap international a
bien été fait prisonnier par les troupes
de kaboul son compagnon vincent lui a
été tué au cours d'une embuscade qui a
été tendu
le 15 août dernier aujourd'hui le chargé
d'affaires afghan a été convoqué au quai
d'orsay
la vente d'hier ling n'est plus tout à
fait ce qu'elle était je fais allusion
bien entendu aux prix le record
aujourd'hui n'a pas excédé les six
millions et demi ce qui n'est pas énorme
quand on se souvient des prix des jeunes
chevaux il ya dix ans le temps des
princes arabes prêt à payer n'importe
quel prix est révolu pierrette brès dans
la tradition de l'élégance et des
chevaux classique c'est la course du
challenge 2 kg qui a servi de cérémonie
d'ouverture aux ventes de yearlings
samedi après-midi réservé exclusivement
aux yeux ring vendu à dori l'année
dernière ce challenge qui offre 2
millions de francs aux vainqueurs a été
créé pour relancer l'intérêt des
acheteurs car ces dernières années des
banderilles hors ligne devenait de plus
en plus catastrophique pour l'ensemble
des éleveurs français
ce fut d'abord monté par guignard qui
remporta l'épreuve
le temps était d'ores et déjà donné ses
allées quel est le haras du quesnay qui
fut le grand animateur de cette première
soirée devant en vendant les coups l'un
des plus chers à plusieurs reprises
millions de francs a largement été
dépassées mais surtout en achetant les
plus beaux numéros pour ses clients
gérard et alain verte nerfs selon
l'habitude le duel des enchères se
déroula surtout entre les princes arabes
les japonais et les anglais et l'enchère
la plus élevée at any 6 millions 500
mille francs pour une soeur de ma biche
acquise par gainsbourg ou pour le cheikh
mohammed
l'enchère la plus élevée n'a pas battu
le record absolu de deauville mais je
crois qu au delà des records si vous
êtes ce qui m'intéresse le plus dans le
résultat de ce soir c'est le pourcentage
de vendus plus de 80% de chevaux de
vendu dans nos ventes c'est un
pourcentage exceptionnel il ya deux ans
on avait vendu 66% des chevaux l'année
dernière 72 % seulement
plus de 80 % cette année je crois c'est
un très bon résultat si leur de
l'association pour l'avenir de son
élevage
il n'en va pas de même pour l'ensemble
des français beaucoup de youri ont été
vendus hier soir à deauville mais
souvent racheté par leur propriétaire
puisqu'il n'y avait pas de prix de
réserve
wade sommes très accessible pour des
chevaux qui représente ce qu'il ya de
mieux sur le marché du pur sang dans nos
ventes nous vendons des chevaux dix
vingt trente mille francs
je crois qu y en a pour tous peuvent y
en a pour toutes les bourses
effectivement si le marché des ventes
il ya dans leur devient abordable c'est
bien pour attirer les petits
propriétaires
l'on peut ainsi inspirer une relance
vécu une souffrance avec beaucoup plus
de chevaux à l'entraînement mais cela
signifie aussi que la politique
d'élevage est complètement à revoir car
la plupart des éleveurs ne peuvent pas
survivre en vendant à perte
ça bouge dans l'année crédit course mais
ça bouge bien dans le sens du progrès et
de l'optimisme
ambiance vacances encore l'été quand la
foule se presse en rangs serrés sur les
plages le problème est bien c'est la
propreté
on a beau prendre soin de s'asseoir sur
sa serviette on finit quand même par
avoir du sable un peu partout et ce
sable n'est pas toujours très nettes
argelès on a décidé de le nettoyer ce
sable grâce à l'eau de mer et à
l'électro les une technique un peu cher
mais qui n'est pas du luxe
nathalie dollé
argelès 7000 habitants l'hiver et 120
milles l'été
le cauchemar estivale d'une station
balnéaire reste le nettoyage de ces
plages publiques six jours sur sept
pendant toute la nuit
la machine sillonne la côte elles
filtrent le sable mais surtout le trade
sur 15 cm de profondeur
grâce au procédé mère active le sable
propre est aspergé d'eau de mer ces taux
étaient activées par procédé unique trop
mythique c'est à dire par courant
électrique qui fait apparaître des
éléments bactéricide puissant qui
permettent donc de tuer systématiquement
tout germe pathogène qui sont contenus
dans la surface dans notre nez de sam on
peut trouver sur certaines plages très
fréquentées jusque 70 milles germes par
gramme de sable responsable de mycoses
et de champignons
après le nettoyage et le traitement les
germes tombe à 4000 par g
le procès des mères actives semble donc
allier l'efficacité d'un super nettoyant
à une conception parfaitement écologique
nous portons à partir de l'eau de mer
uniquement donc il n'y a aucune
adjonction de produits chimiques ou
autre c'est uniquement une décomposition
de donneurs et pour faire partie des
privilégiés qui jouissent d'un sable
parfaitement propre il faut se lever tôt
ou bien encore dormir très tard
toujours dans l'eau jeux panpacifiques
de tokyo ce sont les américains qui
rafle le tout déjà quatre médailles d'or
and moon
80 corps du monde battus par quatre
américains en moins de sept heures du
jamais vu premier record de la journée
celui de janet evans la poupée la
natation américaine
ici en bonnet noir à 17 ans trois titres
de championne olympique elle améliore
son propre record du monde du 800 m nage
libre de 90 centièmes elle confirme sa
place de meilleur mondial sur le
demi-fond le deuxième exploit est signée
mike barrowman au 200 m brasse sont en
deux minutes 12 secondes 89 centièmes
l'américain prend sa revanche deux jours
après qu'un anglais et égaler son
précédent record du monde
quelques minutes plus tard 3e
performance parvint wharton ou 200 m 4
nages
pendant longtemps l'américain était le
second aujourd'hui il devient le
meilleur avec un temps de 2 minutes 11
centièmes pour terminer ces championnats
en apothéose quatrième record celui du
50 m nage libre
l'épreuve qui consacre le nageur le plus
rapide en vitesse pure vainqueur tonnes
jagger en 22 secondes 12 centièmes un an
après les jeux olympiques de séoul les
nageurs américains sont encore au top le
jour
les français ne sont pas mal non plus
encore de la natation le relais français
4 x 100 m nage libre remporté la
médaille d'argent aux championnats
d'europe il y avait aujourd'hui de très
beaux records la médaille d'or de
catherine paley-vincent qui le tandem et
le fameux 3000 m dix huit ans tout
d'abord la natation et le 50 m nage
libre
claude emma concentré catherine
plewinski au départ de ce 50 m nage
libre
la française n'est pas vraiment favorite
mais elle a tout à gagner dans cette
course
elle a tout à gagner et elle va tout
gagner un bon départ d'excellents 25
derniers mètres et les deux allemands de
l'est qui l'entourent sont battus
catherine plewinski en 26 secondes 63
centièmes remporte sa deuxième médaille
d'or dans ces championnats d'europe 1989
solidaire le tandem français fabrice
cola et frédéric magné enlève pour la
troisième année consécutive le titre de
champion du monde de temps dell sur
piste une équipe bien rodée donc qui n'a
pas vraiment connu de problème lors de
la première manche puisque leurs
adversaires les tchécoslovaques ont
abandonné mais là dans la deuxième
manche les français s'imposent à la
régulière après avoir lancé le sprint de
très loin
facile très facile même said aouita sur
ce 3000 mètres du meeting de cologne un
train soutenu et une belle foule et lui
permet d'abord de lâcher le kenyan et
aux baisses on dit équipe qui l'avait
accompagné depuis le début mais surtout
de battre le record du monde
d'environnement en 7 minutes 29 secondes
45 centièmes temps corrigé un nouveau
record pour un 8a qui détient déjà ceux
des canucks en 2000 et 5000 m très beau
la plancha moteur est la dernière née
des jeux de plage le gros avantage de ce
nouvel engin c'est qu'on peut faire du
surf sans avoir besoin d'attendre les
vagues
francis marteau
le lacanau pro 10 ans d'âge
rendez vous de la poule cuivré et de
légumes alors eh bien alors surfer de
tous bords à tout va
mais cette année alain cano les amoureux
de glisse ont découvert une nouvelle
planche une planche à moteur ou plutôt
une planche avec une turbine parce que
la nouvelle glisse c'est cela aussi
les avantages de cette manche et qui
sait qu'elle peut être utilisé ce mot
mais reçoit dans un lac et les enfants
effectivement peuvent l'utiliser parce
que c'est une nouvelle mode de fun de
vitesse et des de glisse 50 kg 50 km
heure maxi le tout propulsé par un
moteur de 9,9
le jet surf c'est encore un nouveau mode
de locomotion sur l'eau seulement
aujourd'hui on ne voit pas toujours cela
d'un bon oeil
on pense évidemment danger alors le
prototype a été étudiée il ya un coupe
circuit qui lorsque la personne tombe du
sort jet s'arrache automatiquement de
l'engin le moteur est alors stockée et
comme il ya une turbine il n'ya pas
d'hélices il n'y a aucun danger pour les
baigneurs qui sont dans le voisinage
actuellement cette planche made in us
est connaît un gros succès de l'autre
côté de l'atlantique
elle aborde désormais les côtes
françaises comme étant la petite soeur
du surf traditionnelle première escale
lacanau seulement pour l'heure peut être
encore un obstacle le prix 25000 francs
c'est vrai que quand on aime on ne
compte pas vraiment alors première
réponse à biarritz cette semaine en
compagnie de la petite soeur
puisqu'elles vont désormais se refait
les mêmes vagues faut quand même rester
prudents avant de vous quitter voici les
rapports du tiercé qui se courait à
deauville il fallait jouer le disent las
et leucate qui rapporte pour 5 francs
2619 francs dans l'ordre et dans un
ordre différent 2 169 francs pour le
quarté il fallait rajouter le 3 il
rapporte pour 6 francs dans l'ordre
22000 153 80 centimes et dans un ordre
différent 900 949 france et ça et 25
ce journal est à présent terminée je
vous remercie de l'avoir suivi demain
vous retrouverez william leymergie à 13
heures demain 20 heures ce sera philippe
lefait et ce soir ce sera thierry
calmette en fin de programme passé une
très bonne soirée sur antenne 2
évidemment je vous retrouverai grand
plaisir le week-end prochain à voir